E
CONFLICT, GILLIAN.
>> Gillian: TREY YINGST,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
AFTERNOON.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> John: THE AIR FORCE ACADEMY
IN COLORADO IS FACING A BACKLASH
FOR AN EMAIL ABOUT A PROGRAM
THAT EXCLUDES SOME CADETS FROM
APPLYING FOR AN AEROSPACE
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM HERE AT THE
EMAIL EXPLAINS THE NINE WEEK
PAID INTERNSHIP IS FOR CISGENDER
WOMEN AND OTHER GENDER MINORITY
AND CISGENDER MEN NEED NOT
APPLY.
FOX NEWS DIGITAL RECEIVED THE
EMAIL FROM A CONCERNED CADET WHO
HEARS THE ECONOMY IS FOCUSING
TOO MUCH ON LOCALISM INSTEAD OF
MILITARY THREATS FACING THE
COUNTRY.
A FORMER CALIFORNIA
GUBERNATORIAL KENNETT AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, CAITLIN,
GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS FRIDAY
AFTERNOON.
LET ME JUST SHOW THE FOLKS AT
HOME WITH THIS EMAIL POINTED TO
HIM UNTIL MICHAEL POINTED TO
WITH THE INTERNSHIP PROGRAM.
IT SAID IF YOU ARE A CISGENDER
WOMAN, TRANSGENDER WOMAN FIND
MARY COMMIT -- MA GENDER, GENDER
FLUID, GENDER QUEER THIS PROGRAM
IS FOR YOU.
IF CISGENDER MALE, THIS PROGRAM
ISN'T FOR YOU.
THIS PROGRAM HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN GEARED TOWARDS WOMEN.
BUT THEY SEEM TO BE CASTING A
FAR WIDER NET AT THE SAME TIME
SAYING MEN, YOU WERE OUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> FIRST OF ALL, DO YOU EVEN
KNOW WHAT ALL OF THOSE
CATEGORIES ARE?
HONESTLY, I'VE NEVER HEARD HALF
OF THE CATEGORIES THAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT, HONESTLY, I DON'T
KNOW.
BUT FIRST OF ALL, GREAT
REPORTING BY FOX DIGITAL THAT
CAME OUT ON SEPTEMBER 14TH.
LET'S DO SOMETHING QUICKLY AND
LET'S COMPARE TRUMPS MILITARY TO
JOE BIDEN'S MILITARY.
FIRST OF ALL, TRUMP WAS ON
HANNITY THE OTHER NIGHT AND HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THIS INCIDENT
THAT HE HAD WITH THE TALIBAN AND
TALKING TO THE LEADER OF THE
TALIBAN.
AND HE BASICALLY SAID TO
HIM, "LOOK, IF YOU DON'T DO
EVERYTHING WE SAY TO DO, WE WILL
BLOW YOU OFF THE FACE OF THE
EARTH."
AND SENT HIM A PICTURE OF HIS
HOME.
AHEAD OF THE TALIBAN SAYS,
"OKAY, I GET YOUR EXCELLENCY."
THAT IS THE POWER I WANT WITH
THE MILITARY.
NOT JOE BIDEN WOKE MILITARY PURE
JOE BIDEN IS MORE INTERESTED IN
PRONOUNS THEN HE IS WHAT OUR
MILITARY IS AND THAT IS THE
FIGHTING FORCE TO PROTECT THIS
COUNTRY.
IT IS A SHAME TO SEE THIS
HAPPEN.
BUT HAS BEEN A PATTERN IN JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT JOE BIDEN
DOES.
AND HONESTLY, IT JUST HAS TO
STOP.
>> John: THIS, AS WE
MENTIONED, THIS EMAIL SENT TO US
BY ANONYMOUS CADET CONCERNED
THAT THE MILITARY IS HYPER
FOCUSED.
AND HERE IS WHAT THE CADET TOLD
FoxNews.com, "IT IS A LITTLE
WORRYING WE HAVE MORE BRIEFS
ABOUT DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
THAN BRIEFS ABOUT FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT OCCUR ACROSS
THE WORLD.
AT THE SAME TIME THE DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION TRAINING AT THE
ACADEMY STRIKES CADETS TO USE
WORDS THAT INCLUDE ALL GENDERS
AND REFRAIN FROM SEEING THINGS
LIKE MOM AND DAD.
THEY SHOULD SAY CAREGIVER OR
PARENT.
THEY SHOULD ALSO SAY FOLKS OR
Y'ALL INSTEAD OF YOU GUYS ARE
PARTNERS A BOYFRIEND OR
GIRLFRIEND.
THIS IS NOT THE MILITARY.
MANY PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT AND
SERVED IN THE MIC AND DIED IN
DEFENSE OF THE COUNTRY.
>> NOT EVEN CLOSE.
LET'S GO BACK IN HISTORY A
LITTLE BIT COMING YOU KNOW, WE
IN WORLD WAR II HAD A SEGREGATED
MILITARY.
THE FLEX HAD THEIR OWN FIGHTING
FORCE UP ON THE SIDE BUT ALSO,
THEY WORKED HARD TO DO THE BEST
JOB THEY POSSIBLY COULD AND THEY
GOT SO GOOD AT FLYING AND
PROTECTING OUR BOMBERS GOING IN
THAT THEY DID A PHENOMENAL JOB.
AND THEN THEY WERE REQUESTING
IT.
AND TODAY, WE ARE DOING THE
OPPOSITE, YOU KNOW?
WE ARE TRYING TO RE-SEGREGATE
OUR MILITARY.
THIS IS WHAT THE BLACK DOES,
THEY DEFIED EVERYBODY UP INTO A
DIFFERENT SEGMENT IN DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS, YOU ARE NOT AS
POWERFUL.
WHEN YOU GET TOGETHER AND YOU
ARE A POWERFUL COMIC FIGHTING
UNIT, YOU CAN DO ANYTHING YOU
NEED.
THIS IS ABOUT THE LEFTS DIVISION
AN END IT'S ABOUT IDENTITY
POLITICS.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, THE BEST
WAY TO DO DIVERSITY TRAINING,
LIVE IN THE REAL WORLD.
>> John: CAITLIN TURNER,
ALWAYS GREAT